for Democrats they're very reticent to
give the Trump Administration credit for
anything just due to you know
traditional partisan politics and then
for Republicans obviously everyone knows
vaccines are highly controversial and
divisive within the Republican party and
so you know we're seeing presidential
candidates in the next election kind of
running away from this huge success if
you flash back to Trump introducing this
concept we've we've pulled a clip from
2020 when he first was rolling out
operation warp speed which will play in
just a second the reaction to that was
quite interesting and telling um from
from both sides and things have kind of
flipped back and forth multiple times
but let's have a Adam our our producer
here uh play that clip and then talk
about that issue for just a second it
appears to be employing the promise of a
vaccine as part of his re-election
strategy today he took three
opportunities to suggest that we could
couldn't even see a vaccine by election
day so what's the earliest we could see
that a vaccine uh sooner than the end of
the year could be much sooner sooner
than November 3rd
oh I think I think in some cases yeah
it's possible before but right around
that time I believe we'll have the
vaccine before the end of the year
certainly but around that date yes I
think so
it wouldn't hurt it wouldn't hurt but
I'm not doing that I'm doing it not for
the election I want it fast because I
want to save a lot of lives under
operation warp speed to vaccines are
already in the final stage of clinical
trials and will have a vaccine very soon
I hope long before the end of the year
Dr Anthony fauci weighed in on that with
his own reality check
we're trying very hard to ultimately get
a vaccine that might be available by the
end of the year or the beginning of 2021
but that's many months away
so you know what strikes me about that
you know first of all is fauci seemed to
be pretty much cautiously agreeing with
Trump on the timeline despite how Brian
Williams was was characterizing at the
time and secondly you know it's a
reminder that the hesitancy back then
was coming often from the political left
uh we've got a tweet here from Eric
topple a well-known uh Twitter MD who uh
at the time was stumping and success
here in the Tweet he's actually kind of
bragging about the fact that he his
efforts delayed the authorization of the
vaccines until after the presidential
election
this was right in the midst of a major
covid wave so
who knows how many lives that
potentially cost but
um yeah I am curious from your
perspective as someone who's trying to
put together this kind of trans-partisan
coalition to look at uh issues of
technological progress or medical
progress
how what are some of the strategies
you're using to try to overcome that
that kind of partisanship
yeah I like that you use that phrase
transpartisan Coalition because that's a
term we like to use a lot
um here internally within our
organization I think for some of your
audience that might be a new term
they've obviously sort of heard of
bipartisan or nonpartisan but the way we
think of transpartisan by contrast is
that if bipartisanship is a messy
compromise where one side gets half of
what they want other side gets half what
they want then everyone kind of walks
away dissatisfied with the bipartisan
compromise a transpartisan deal would be
if Republicans and Democrats support the
same policy but for different reasons
and so I think operation warp speed is a
great example of in theory and not
practices are different but in theory it
has a lot to offer each party so
Democrats like to say they're Pro
science Pro Public Health
um they're pro-masking you know all the
things that go along in that bucket and
operational Works be delivered you know
these amazing biomedical Innovations
very very quickly
um and then for Republicans there's
often a concern
um you know every year around wasting
taxpayer money so whenever the
government has you know a multi-billion
dollar big public spending program
there's skepticism that like the
government will get a return on its
investment or it's worthwhile and I
think some of the tools they used in
operation warp speed could be used again
for their programs and the key is that
you're paying for performance so
government said we're going to do
pre-purchase contracts with all these
companies that participated in the
program and if they you know deliver
invent a safe and effective vaccine
approved by the FDA then we'll purchase
hundreds of millions of doses from the
company but the company can't you know
deliver on its end then the government
does not spend the money and so I think
that kind of public-private partnership
um that protects taxpayer money should
be highly appealing to Republicans and
then also talking about you know the
feasible alternative at that point in
time if you don't get the vaccines
quickly is a continued you know quasi
lockdown in much of the country and so
what's the more you know Freedom
oriented Liberty oriented thing to do
it's to get the vaccines out quicker as
opposed to more Draconian measures that
would need to be happening in a counter
factual scenario but why did government
need to guarantee demand in that manner
yeah so again I think this is where like
there's a hindsight situation where we
know at this point in time that there
were lots of variants the pandemic ended
up dragging on for two to three years
even post you know when the vaccines
were available we can go more into like
promises around transmission and things
like that with the vaccines but yeah
um I think it's it's useful to look at
previous
um epidemics around the world and this
is what obviously vaccine manufacturers
and pharmaceutical companies do
um there were previous SARS outbreaks in
East East Asia that seemed like they
might become Global pandemics But
ultimately didn't and so if you were a
vaccine manufacturer
um in particular building capacity of
like are we going to actually start
winding up manufacturing capacity to
deliver hundreds of millions and
ultimately billions of doses of vaccine
you're going to really wait and see
cautious scenario you wouldn't want to
sink too much money into fixed
Investments that ultimately there might
be close to zero demand for the vaccine
and so the government is de-risking that
they're guaranteeing demand for the
product so long as you meet the the
performance metrics in terms of it's
safe it's effective as a term by the FDA
you know that could have been a world we
lived in where the pandemic did Peter
out for other reasons and they still
invented safe infected vaccines and then
we bought a lot of doses we couldn't use
um but that's the kind of I think
preparation you need to have for the
worst case scenario and we were in a bad
scenario where a pandemic just kept
going we want to go through each
individual component of operation warp
speed just to understand exactly how it
works and exactly what lessons we want
to learn but I think it's kind of
important to address like the the you
know what the vaccine did and didn't
deliver you know what what we all kind
of think about that because that that is
partially you know how you judge whether
it was a success whether it you know
what level of protection did it deliver
what what level of risk did it bring
with it and you know just from our
previous conversation I think where Liz
and I are both kind of coming from and
you can chime in here Liz if you want to
is that you know vaccines were on net
imperfect and certainly far from
perfectly introduced but overall a
lifesaver a Net Life Saver and we're
we're both keenly aware on the heels of
some recent work that we put out that a
certain segment of our audience strongly
disagrees with that but I do take it as
extremely likely at this point that the
vaccines on that saved a lot of lives
which you can see just by observing the
gap between vaccinated and unvaccinated
deaths per capita is there anything else
you want to say on that point Alec or
Liz before we move forward
yeah I'll just add there that yeah I
think that the data we have is extremely
um strong that the vaccines save lives
on net
um but yeah it's not to say that the
operation warp speed or the messaging
from public health officials following
you know
um the invention of the vaccines was
perfect and I think the key mistake they
made in terms of communication was and
again it's well intentioned they wanted
to encourage people to get the vaccine
because they wanted to save lives and
hopefully end the pandemic was they made
claims about the vaccine's effect on
transmission of the virus from person to
person that I think ultimately did not
hold up in real world settings right
that's because the clinical trials
weren't designed to test uh you know the
the effect on transmissibility and but
the vaccine the the clinical trials were
designed to precisely measure effects on
severe outcomes in terms of
hospitalization and death and those
outcomes mostly did hold up in real
world effects and so talking about like
reductions in in severe disease and
death and that's a huge benefit but I
think understandable if people were
promised like hey
get this vaccine you're going to protect
your friends and family you're not going
to infect them
um and you know and also you won't you
won't die yourself
um that that transmissibility part I
think no um they didn't deliver on and
they shouldn't have made that claim in
the first place because they didn't have
the evidence so that was a kind of
messaging error from the CDC and the
public health establishment more so than
some sort of failure of operation warp
speed exactly yeah but I think they're
also not so separable just because
um operation warp speed was
um an interagency effort
um all those officials were also being
asked all the time to comment on these
particular things and so um we held an
event uh last fall with the original
operation warm speed team that's one of
the things that
um secretary Azar said he wishes they
had done differently is they would have
um handled Communications differently he
didn't say anything particular about you
know operations or you know how the
contracts were written but it was around
how they were communicating with the
public I struggle with this a lot
because it seems like so many pandemic
era Health authorities are very um sort
of like late with their apologies and
then very imprecise in it and it's like
well I would actually have preferred not
to have been nobly lied to and a little
bit more of a robust atoning for such
sins and learning from those mistakes
and ideally some of those people being
out of jobs would probably leave a
better taste in my mouth the other thing
that I think about here because I'm very
grateful for vaccines being administered
to the 70 or 70 and 80 year olds in my
life but the other thing that I keep
coming back to was like was there really
a reason for like New York City where I
live to force children to be vaccinated
in order to like go dine inside in
restaurants in the winter with their
families just given the um the what we
know about transmission and then also
given the mortality risk to you know
six-year-olds and seven-year-olds that
just seemed totally unjustifiable to me
but you know of course this was this
Patchwork of federal government policy
and you know media pressure and then
lots and lots of localities in States
making their own decisions on these
things and New York was a particularly
dumb and bad place around of this
um I do want to go into a few more
specifics though so like what were the
specific components of operation warp
speed you guys identify like you know a
few different prongs basically the thing
that I'm really curious about in general
would you mind describing for our
audience
solving market failures using
market-shaped mechanisms what exactly
are those what do those actually mean
what did they look like in this case for
sure and just one quick comment on what
you said about the you know the I think
this Patchwork thing is so important
um this is where again like I would just
separate what ifp works on and kind of
our mission from other you know really
controversial tricky public policy
questions that are gonna be handled in
different states and cities across the
country which is we think there should
at least be agreement that it's really
good to quickly invent a safe and
effective vaccine and then that's
outside of our wheelhouse in terms of
what's the best policy in New York City
you know what are the values and
decisions that go into regulations
around access to public spaces
um those are really important questions
other people can can kind of decide but
I think what we shouldn't do is let that
latter conversation affect whether we
you know design government programs to
work with Private Industry that invent
the vaccine in the first place hey
thanks for watching that excerpt from
our conversation with Alex stop of the
institute for progress about operation
warp speed the Trump Administration plan
to accelerate development of covid-19
vaccines if you liked it you can watch
the full interview right here or another
clip right here